[Musik]
nehmt mir da bitte die zwei händen ab
wir sind gut erinnern
braucht keiner hin
[Applaus]
mit scott nachbarin auf die hennen welt
zwei sequenz bauer sage euch um
lichtmess van sant und legen bis tief in
winter und wie ein einziges verlegt
alles ins netz bowes inc
[Musik]
wir sind hier im berliner ensemble dem
alten brecht theater in berlin und hier
ist einzigartig mal etwas zu erleben was
es sonst eben nicht gibt bei den
vergessenen stücken hier kann man eines
der vergessene stücke live erleben
pandemie bedingt kann die wirklich sehr
eindrucksvolle inszenierung von michael
thalheimer leider nicht gezeigt werden
aber bis zur wiederaufführung lohnt die
lektüre dieses glaubens dramas wirklich
sehr
in dieser inszenierung gibt es
fantastische schauspieler ist eine sehr
präzise und prägnante entstehung einer
vor allem zieht einen in den bann das
bühnenbild in dieser inszenierung mit
einer unfassbaren wucht die einen noch
lange beschäftigt und die einen nachgeht
und weil das so ist weil dieses thema
der gewalt hier so einzigartig in ein
bild gefunden hat sprechen wir als
erstes mit der bühnenbildnerin dieser
grandiosen produktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da war irgendwie dieser gedanke ok
heimat flucht gewalt vertreibung
ich brauche nord ich brauche zentrum ja
also in dem punkt ist es so zu sagen
dass man diesen mittelpunkt betont und
ich hatte mal irgendwie so ein uhr ort
wollte ich eigentlich machen ja sonst
und den ort schlechthin und dann gab es
in dem stück diesen diese studie mit am
ofen und im zweiten bild ist es glaube
ich der brunnen und dem dritten bild es
ist der baum mit einer bank und da kommt
es irgendwie ja schon so direkt zusammen
nur dass man sagt das ist so irgendwie
geht es so um vielleicht etwas wo man
sich hinsetzen kann oder was so in
unseren kunden wie definiert und dann
dachte ich ziehe das in eine massive
große architektur
und dann war auch ganz schnell klar dass
eigentlich mit dieser zweifeln und uns
sich quälen was ist meine entscheidung
es ist ja auch er glaube und heimat oder
glaube oder heimat dann in dem fall dass
man
was man sagt man dreht das ganze also es
ist sozusagen dieses ständige rotieren
um diesen punkt was euch tun wo soll ich
hin gehör ich hin mache ich das mache
ich das nicht was ist wichtiger und und
dieses rotieren war dann eigentlich die
idee dass man vision einer schraube
bedingungen
ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich jetzt in
deutschland dieser heimatbegriff immer
mit sowas heime liegen oder sowas netten
verbunden habe ich glaube heimat kann
auch das absolute gegenteil seien nun ja
ich fand wichtig dass man es irgendwie
in das auch hat gesagt das ist somit
ganz klare architektur ist und es ist
innen und außenraum zugleich eigentlich
durch diese bank die drum herum führt
und weil ich eben auch davon gesprochen
hatte wie geht man mit so einem raum um
also diese bank war irgendwie so ein
ganz wichtiger punkt für mich auch wenn
es nur ein kleines element ist aber dass
man diese diese familienbilder und
dieses sitzen und haaren und und dann in
der drehung eben auch spielerisch damit
umgehen kann dass man das dass man das
bauen kann
die sagen das soll einmal möglich wirken
gesteckt haben erreichen wissen dass
jetzt haut gern mit dem sammeln um das
alle bürger bauen
jetzt lassen wir das theater hinter uns
und begeben uns auf eine andere bühne
sie waren nämlich jetzt zu einem boxclub
in kreuzberg und verfolgen das thema
gewalt das bei schönherr stückler und
heimat ja so zentral ist und was wir
gerade hier ästhetisch betrachtet haben
auf einer ganz anderen seite nämlich auf
der sozialen seite besprechen mit einem
trainer in diesen boxclub über
gewaltprävention und seinen blick auf
das thema gewalt
im prinzip sobald sich hier durch die
tür kommen ja findet schon so eine
erzieherische maßnahme stadt ja es geht
da ganz viele ja respekt gegenüber den
anderen selbstbewusstsein entwickeln
wir geben den versuchen die leute
natürlich werte mit zu geben wie zum
beispiel auch selbstreflektion dem mut
und disziplin und natürlich auch
freundlichkeit da es waren ganz viele
jungs er die muss man erst mal zu
konditionieren das ja auch lernen
einfach mal pünktlich zum training zu
erscheinen
[Musik]
wir gehen hier raus die sind im kopf
frei haben stress abgebaut der
serotoninspiegel guten stress abzubauen
gehen raus und ich glaube nicht dass das
bedürfnis dann da ist auf der strasse
irgendwie irgendwie preis zu
veranstalten
was wir natürlich auch konsequent
ablehnen
die wissen auch wenn sie das auf der
straße umsätzen sind sie hier raus genau
wenn die erstmal hier sind um feuer
gefangen haben und so haben die
natürlichen halt ein ziel
selbstbewusstsein wird natürlich
ausgebildet ja aber auch so sachen wie
sich mal selber zu reflektieren zu
gucken was gar nicht besser machen ja es
ist immer ein kampf auch gegen sich
selbst und das lernen die hier auch da
mal hin zu gucken wie bewege ich mich
aber auch natürlich im wettkampfbereich
auch in der lage umzugehen
das ist so wichtig fürs leben in meinem
leben einen rückschlag hat muss man sich
auch erst mal sammeln wieder neue kräfte
mobilisieren gucken
was kann man besser machen und auch
nicht und dann geht das leben weiter und
das lernen wir als ihr gönner
[Applaus]
[Musik]